[Música]
[Aplausos]
les voy a pedir por favor que miren este
digo
que ven
muy bien
qué falta
piso
árboles
ropa está desnudo sí
sabes lo que yo veo
yo veo un millón de personas
veo a la familia de ese hombre
están todos adentro de la casa
veo a las personas que construyeron esta
casa
trabajaron duro durante meses y cuando
terminaron hicieron una celebración
vea los vecinos del barrio
veo las juntas de vecinos
veo navidades
cuando yo era chico mi papá me dibujaba
siempre ese dibujo
y yo me hacía siempre la misma pregunta
dónde están todos
cómo se construye esa casa
con una sola persona
hoy les vengo a contar una verdad mi
verdad
las personas no necesitamos
y eso no quiere decir que el colectivo
sea más importante que el individuo pero
las personas desde siempre nos hemos
necesitado somos seres sociales
el primer acercamiento que tenemos a la
sociedad es la familia
por ejemplo cuánta democracia hay al día
domingo al elegir el almuerzo en
nuestras casas o es una dictadura como
en la mía
o por ejemplo cuánto sabes sobre tus
derechos o deberes sabes que tienes el
deber de hacer la cama pero no siempre
tienes el derecho de salir
ya mi mamá déjame salir estoy encerrado
todo el fin de semana
la familia es lo primero que reconocemos
como sociedad y la escuela en los
segundos
hace más o menos 13.000 años atrás el
ser humano descubrió lo que hoy
conocemos como civilización
ese fue el punto de partida para el
desarrollo de la humanidad y en ese
momento nacieron las escuelas
como un lugar donde alcanzar el máximo
conocimiento
a los tres años abandonamos nuestra
primera sociedad
para entrar en una nueva y más compleja
cuando entré a la escuela me encontré
con mis profesores con mis directores
con mis tíos del aseo con mis primeros
profesores
ahí construimos relaciones y
experimentamos los valores como el
respeto y la justicia
ahora
necesito que levanten la mano todos y
todas las personas que se consideran a
políticas
1 2 3 4 5
muy bien
primero tenemos que saber que aprendemos
a hablar y omitimos su opinión queremos
influir en otra persona
por lo tanto considerarse una persona
apolítica no es precisamente correcto
todos tenemos un punto de vista y
queremos hacerlo valer así que esperando
que todos y todas las personas de este
auditorio tengan una opinión y la hagan
valer les vuelva a ser la pregunta quién
de ustedes se considera una persona
apolítica
muy bien
yo la verdad es que siempre tuve algo
que decir
y tal como dice el experto el liderazgo
robin se arma
la más insignificante de las acciones
siempre es mejor que la más audaz de las
intenciones
decidí que si quería haber cambios
significativas en mi escuela tenía que
ser algo al respecto es por esto que
hace dos años atrás decidí postular más
centro de alumnos la escuela de la
industria gráfica que es donde me estoy
formando propone que los alumnos debemos
postularnos al centro de alumnos de
manera individual
qué significa esto
que uno va se abre las postulaciones se
postula y una vez que se hace en las
votaciones por cada uno se junta todo el
equipo nosotros no nos conocemos
primer desafío construir un proyecto
común
a medida que pasaba el tiempo nos dimos
cuenta que no nos conocíamos no había un
proyecto que nos uniera y es aquí el
primer cáncer de las escuelas
hoy por experiencia propia puedo decir
que en una escuela técnico-profesional a
la organización interna de los
estudiantes no se le da la suficiente
importancia
no es que no seamos jóvenes
revolucionarios no es así
es que no tenemos la suficiente guía
para poder generar los espacios de
participación juvenil
hoy 2018 pleno siglo 21 casas como el
mío se replican por no decir en todas en
la mayoría de las escuelas técnicas
los estudiantes de educación técnica
representamos el 40 por ciento de la
matrícula total del país
yo me pregunto cómo es posible que el 40
por ciento de la población estudiantil
no sepa usar un espacio de participación
juvenil
el estudio internacional de educación
cívica y formación ciudadana que estuve
cuatro semanas aprendiendo me ese nombre
dice que en el contexto escolar en
conocimiento cívico
somos el quinto país
- sabe sobre educación cívica
en relación a todo el mundo
existe poca preparación de los docentes
en el tema
y en base a esto
y encontró el estudio el conocimiento
cívico de los estudiantes está bajo la
media internacional
pero lo más delicado esto es que no
mejora desde 2009
son nueve generaciones hasta el 2018 que
no saben participar que no saben usar
los espacios de expresión
en fin
cuál es la invitación
yo los invito a todos los jóvenes a usar
los espacios de participación a
informarse estos datos son preocupantes
no porque lo diga yo
informarse sobre lo que está pasando en
el país no es grave no es importante
porque lo estoy diciendo yo nosotros
antes de ser trabajadores antes de ser
estudiantes somos ciudadanos y debemos
hacernos cargo de las decisiones que se
tienen que tomar en este país
yo veo
un millón de personas y ustedes cuántas
ven muchas gracias
[Aplausos]